that room you're in looks like so much
fun you got all those records are those
is that your entire record collection or
is that just
one small portion just what i brought
down to listen to in here no it's it's
uh
30 times that wow yeah that's just some
good stuff
alice cooper uh yeah there's some alice
cooper in there there's some welcome to
my nightmare
captain fantastic sounded good the other
night yeah
fugazi there's about six fugazi records
ah
fleet with matt cause my wife and i like
to have kind of dance parties they they
we've been having these garage dance
parties all those guitars on your wall
are those your personal guitars or those
guitars people gave you
those three right there those are what
we call them rickenbackers
now did you like the band absolutely so
that bass actually belonged to rick
danko
and if you see the last waltz and he's
playing the weight
with the staple singers and that's
actually that one there
and the three guitars over your shoulder
there those are your personal guitars or
those ones
that that belong to someone else you
know i grew up with certain kind of
guitars
that uh were like the holy grail of
guitar so in the middle one
that one if you plug it in it actually
lights go on on the inside it's called
the rickenbacker light show
from the mid 60s it's a little too
gimmicky for you isn't it i mean i'm
surprised that's it yeah but it's an
amazing invention you know
have you ever played that on stage just
once yeah
um the one on the right is a they call
it a convertible so it was a invention
they used for like a year and it can
either go from six strings to 12 strings
you kind of
have this little device i like the weird
invention kind of
the weird [ __ ] and then the one on the
left you know i was looking for one of
those for a while
and there aren't a bunch of those left
because p-towns and those were the ones
that he was smashing all the time
i heard that they used to smash them but
they they had a guy who put him back
together after the show because they
didn't have that much money to who in
the beginning did you ever read that
well yeah the guy's name was pete
townsend yeah
right he told you screw him back back
together oh my goodness